en su discurso nocturno a la nación
volodymyr selenski adoptó un tono
especialmente serio habló de la traición
de los funcionarios en beneficio de los
rusos
hasta la fecha se han registrado 651
procedimientos penales por traición al
estado y actividades de colaboración por
parte de empleados de las fiscalías
instituciones judiciales y otros
organismos encargados de hacer cumplir
la ley y
entre ellos había más de 60 empleados de
la fiscalía y los servicios de seguridad
ucranianos ante las sospechas de que
algunos de sus subordinados están
implicados volodymyr de lenski toma
precauciones con sus directivos
he tomado la decisión de destituir a la
fiscal general y al jefe de los
servicios de seguridad cremiento
la primera es irina benedicto va esta
abogada estuvo a cargo de procesar los
crímenes de guerra rusos aquí la vemos
en abril acompañada de gendarmes
franceses tras la masacre debuta en los
suburbios de kiev ella dirigía la
investigación en ese momento
por desgracia tenemos mucho trabajo con
los crímenes de guerra y los crímenes
contra la humanidad también fue
destituido el jefe de la agencia de
inteligencia iván vaca nov un hombre muy
cercano al presidente